unifier la gauche pour ce lancement de
campagne présidentielle dans les
yvelines les socialistes n'ont pas
hésité à marteler ce mot d'ordre
oui j'y crois parce qu'il est nécessaire
indispensable comme l'a souligné michel
pouzol c'est soit ça soit on est mort je
pense que monsieur mélenchon
ne veut absolument pas rejoindre le
parti socialiste dans lequel il a
pourtant militer de nombreuses années
c'est un peu dommage
aujourd'hui on a vu que yannick jadot
avait fait le par vers benoît hamon et
j'espère beaucoup de tout coeur que jean
luc mélenchon fera aussi le pas vers
benoît hamon afin qu'on ait une gauche
unitaire pour pouvoir gagner faire
gagner nos idées
les verts et le ps dorénavant main dans
la main une nouvelle largement commentée
ici à la ferme de bel ébat cuit en cours
ce dimanche matin on a discuté largement
et que élevé ghislaine sénat était là
aujourd'hui pour aussi apporté son
soutien à une dynamique à gauche je
rencontre le parti communiste
pour tout vous dire demain donc voilà il
ya ya évidemment des discussions qui
sont en cours
allier les valeurs socialistes avec les
valeurs communistes front de gauche de
la france insoumise les valeurs
citoyennes et les valeurs écologistes
je crois que ce serait le plus gros un
programme en tout cas est le plus bel
espoir que l'on peut donner aux français
benoît hamon toujours député des
yvelines pourra compter en tout cas sur
le soutien de sa fédération
dans le département il avait obtenu plus
de 58% des suffrages lors de la primaire
de la gauche
[Applaudissements]